à vermenton la tour du méridien fait
peau neuve à 35 mètres de hauteur un
campanile flambant neuf et délicatement
posée sur l'édifice une opération
périlleuse
on a eu très peur ils nous ont fait très
président dit que le vieux campanile au
moment où il allait désolidarisé de la
tour comme il était très en très mauvais
état il pouvait exploser en gros
l'ancien campanile de cto du 15e siècle
menaçait de s'effondrer un morceau
c'était d'ailleurs détachés l'an dernier
moins coûteux que de le rénover il a été
remplacé à l'identique les habitants
admire le nouveau visage du monument
j'ai vu le nouveau
avant qu'il soit monté sur place c'est
vraiment du beau travail un
travail formidable j'ai toujours connu
dans l'ancien et quand je
je ne vois là qu'était rénové
tout ça c'est
c'est sympa quoi manificat
c'est très beau
charpente couverture en ardoise g wet en
cuivre le nouveau dôme a été
confectionnée par un artisan de la
région avec des matériaux récent mais
tout en respectant l'architecturé du
précédent campanile on a appris beaucoup
c'est le gros avantage de de reprendre
un bâtiment ancien comme ça c'est qu'on
en apprend sur la robustesse sur sur les
assemblages sur tout ça et on à corriger
leurs erreurs si je peux dire qu'il
avait des erreurs mais de façon à ce que
ça fasse encore plus longtemps et dans
le meilleur circonstances
moi je pense 120 ans cent vingt ans je
mise sur 120 ans sans problème l'ancien
compagnie lui prend la route vers le
parc du village c'est une nouvelle page
de son histoire qui s'ouvre il devrait
être transformé en kiosque